THANK YOU.
I'M GOING TO TURN OUT TO THE
ONGOING BATTLE BETWEEN CNN AND
THE WHITE HOUSE.
CNN CELEBRATED THEIR LEGAL
VICTORY WHEN JIM ACOSTA GOT HIS
PRESS PASS REINSTATED.
DOES IT MEAN FOR EVERYONE ELSE?
BYRON YORK WRITING YESTERDAY,
THE DECISION COULD MAKE IT
EASIER FOR WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS
TO KICK REPORTERS OUT.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS HIS
FORMER WHITE HOUSE SECRETARY,
SEAN SPICER.
ALONG WITH FORMER RONALD REAGAN
AID AND AUTHOR OF THE
FORTHCOMING BOOK, SMALL PORES.
JEFFREY LORD.
GENTLEMEN, LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
NEW RULES THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
LAID OUT FOR REPORTERS.
WILL THEY BE FOLLOWED BY ACOSTA
AND HIS COLLEAGUES?
IS THE WHITE HOUSE GOING TO NEED
TO COME UP WITH THREE STRIKES
AND YOU'RE OUT PLAN.
WHAT IS YOUR VIEW ON THIS NEW
ANNOUNCEMENT?
>> IT IS GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I TALKED ABOUT THIS AND MY
PODCAST WITH KELLYANNE CONWAY.
THIS IS A DISCUSSION ABOUT
CONTENT VERSUS CONDUCT.
I THINK THERE IS A VERY CAPABLE
PRESS SECRETARY THAT IS ABLE TO
DISCERN THE DIFFERENCE OF 22.
NO ONE HAS A QUESTION ABOUT THE
CONTENT OF ANY REPORTER'S
QUESTION.
THEY CAN ASK WHATEVER THEY WANT.
THEIR CONDUCT IS WHAT IS IN
QUESTION.
THAT IS WHAT THE JUDGE RULED.
WILL HE BEHAVE IN A WAY THAT IS
PROFESSIONAL?
WILL THE RESPECT NOT JUST THE
OFFICE BUT THEIR FELLOW
REPORTERS?
THAT IS WHAT THIS COMES DOWN TO.
THERE IS A GREAT PRICE
SECRETARY NOW.
YOU MAY KNOW HER.
SHE KNOWS HOW TO CALL BALLS AND
STRIKES.
THERE IS A PRESIDENT WHO KNOWS I
DO UNDERSTAND THAT AS WELL.
THIS IS WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.
FOR OTHER ORGANIZATIONS, NO
NAMES MENTIONED, YOU MAY GUESS
THEM ARE TRYING TO BLUR THE
LINES IS THE QUESTION ABOUT WHAT
THE CONTENT IS.
NO ONE CARES WHAT THE REPORTER
ASKS.
THEY CAN ASK WHATEVER QUESTIONS
THEY WANT.
WITH THAT THESE REPORTERS
CONDUCT THEMSELVES, DID THEY
CONDUCT THEMSELVES AND SHOW
RESPECT NOT ONLY THE FELLOW
REPORTERS BUT TO THE PRESIDENT?
THAT IS WHAT IS IN QUESTION.
>> Mike: JEFFREY, THE JUDGE
RULED IN A RATHER NARROW WAY
THAT HE DID NOT SAY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT WAS IN ANY WAY
BEING ATTACKED BY JIM ACOSTA
LOSING HIS PAST.
IT WAS THE PROCESS WAS NOT FULLY
VISIBLE TO THE WORLD.
THEREFORE HIS FIFTH AMENDMENT
ISSUE WAS THE ONLY ONE.
THEY CELEBRATED AS IF SOMEHOW
THEY HAD TAKEN A STAND FOR
DEMOCRACY.
I DON'T REMEMBER ANY OF THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA BEING THAT
CLEVER, CLEAR AND HONEST ABOUT
WHAT THAT      THAT RULING WAS.
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
SEAN HAS HAD THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD.
THIS IS ABOUT CONTACT.
NOT ABOUT CONTENT.
THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS WE HAVE
HEARD FROM GARRETT FROM CBS.
THE OBAMA DAYS HE WAS THE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT FOR
FOX.
NO ONE REMEMBERS HIM ACTING LIKE
JIM ACOSTA.
THAT IS BECAUSE HE DIDN'T.
THERE WAS A DEEP WAY          WY
THERE WAS A DEEP WAY          WO
THERE WAS A DEEP WAY          WT
THERE WAS A DEEP WAY          WI
THERE WAS A DEEP WAY          W.
THIS IS TOTALLY UNPROFESSIONAL
STUFF.
I THINK THAT CNN HAS TO BE VERY
CAREFUL HERE OF WHAT THEY WISH
FOR.
IF THERE'S GOING TO BE A SET OF
RULES AND REGULATIONS, THE GOOD
PRESS SECRETARY THAT SARAH IS,
SHE WILL CALL THEM OUT.
ONE OTHER THING, I TOOK A QUICK
LOOK BACK AT A MEMORY FROM
CHILDHOOD.
JFK'S PRESS CONFERENCES.
HE HAD ADVERSARIAL REPORTERS.
THEY WERE SO WELL MANNERED.
IT IS BEYOND BELIEF.
WE'VE GONE SO FAR DOWN THE PATH
AND IN THE WRONG DIRECTION WITH
THE STAFF.
IT IS ALMOST UNBELIEVABLE AND I
THINK CNN AND JIM ACOSTA WILL
COME TO    TO A CREDIT AND SO WL
THEIR COMPADRES IN THE ROOM.
>> I WANT TO KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THE THOUGHT THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
ASSOCIATION IS NOT GOING TO HAVE
A COMEDIAN WROTE THE MEDIA NEXT
YEAR, WHICH IS KNOWN AS THE
ANNUAL NERD PROM.
INSTEAD THEY WILL HAVE BROAD
TURN NOW BE THE FEATURED SPEAKER
TO PUT SOME PERSPECTIVE ON
TODAY'S POLITICS.
LAST YEAR SPEAKER, MICHELLE WOLF
TWEETED THIS IN RESPONSE.
SHE SAID, THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT ASSOCIATION ARE
COWARDS.
THE MEDIA IS COMPLICIT.
I COULDN'T BE PROUDER.
FIRST OF ALL, MATCH OR THEY HAD
A COMEDIAN LAST YEAR.
THAT MICHELLE WOLF AND SHE JUST
WASN'T FUNNY.
SEAN, WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO
THE FACT THAT THE CORRESPONDENTS
ASSOCIATION FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN DECADES HAS DECIDED THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE THAT
KIND OF LACK OF POLITICAL HUMOR?
>> HERE'S MY RESPONSE, I APPLAUD
OLIVIA KNOX AND THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT ASSOCIATION FOR
DOING THIS.
THEY WANT TO HAVE A DINNER THAT
CELEBRATES THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
IT ACTUALLY SHOWS THAT THAT IS
WHAT THEIR INTENT IS.
I APPLAUD THEM FOR IT.
LAST YEAR THEY WANTED TO HAVE A
COMEDIAN AND THEY TALKED ABOUT
HOW THIS COMEDIAN, MICHELLE WOLF
WOULD CONDUCT HERSELF AND TALK
ABOUT THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
IT WASN'T.
IT WAS RUDE, IT WAS DISGUSTING.
I THINK FOR THEM TO AT LEAST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT THEY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND HAVE A
HISTORIAN DO IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY WILL TALK
ABOUT, BUT AT LEAST THEIR INTENT
IS RIGHT.
I WILL GIVE THEM CREDIT FOR
THAT.
LAST YEAR'S DINNER WAS
DISGUSTING.
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS MORE
APPALLING ABOUT THE DINNER AND
ANYTHING IS THAT THEY BRANDED IT
AS THE FIRST AMENDMENTS.
THE COMEDIAN, IF THAT'S WHAT YOU
CALL HER, WASN'T THAT.
NO ONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT, CNN, NBC, SAID
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS PERSON
CONDUCTED THEMSELVES IN THE
SPIRIT OF THE FIRST AMENDMENTS.
TO SEE THEM AT LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THAT WASN'T THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IS AT LEAST SOMETHING
THAT I WANT TO APPLAUD AND SAY,